and Bloomberg or maybe blue maybe Alexa
knows workers are listening Amazon
workers are listening to what you tell
Alexa Alexa ad wrapping paper to the
shopping list I've put wrapping paper on
your shopping list echo an investigation
revealed Amazon employs thousands of
people worldwide who listen to voice
recordings captured by the company's
digital assistant Alexa Amazon
acknowledged the listening and released
a statement that said in part we only
annotate an extremely small number of
interactions from a random set of
customers in order to improve the
customer experience employees do not
have direct access to information that
can identify the person or account as
part of this workflow CBS News
contributor and wired editor-in-chief
Nick Thompson joins us at the table Nick
good morning that Bloomberg article also
reported that a lot of this listening is
going on in an unmarked building in
Romania not a good look
what are what is the legitimate business
purpose of this for Amazon they're
trying to make it better when you say
you want wrapping paper add it to your
list and it here's raccoon paper or
whatever adheres it likes to go back to
human and see why it made a mistake or
why it gave you the wrong answer it is
trying to improve the service
lots of artificial intelligent systems
do this they having machines give you
answers and they've the humans check it
they feed the humans checking back into
the machine machine gets better that's
for a special kind of party racoon paper
the company wants to make it sound as if
this is all benign and it very well
might be but when you have thousands of
people doing this and the companies
saying very small limited amount those
things don't seem to line up to me am I
wrong
well it can so yes there are lots of
people doing this this is a huge
operation right thousands of people big
operation on the other hand their
intentions are definitely to make the
service better but it is also true that
you should feel weird about it it is
really really weird and they say there's
no identifiable information right they
don't tie it to your name
but what if we're talking and I say hey
Alexa give this to major Garrett major
Garrett's being difficult onset that's
pretty identifiable and the person's
gonna listen to it and know what's going
on right yeah yeah well I think Alexis
already knew that like 20 minutes ago in
the Bloomberg report a couple of the the
workers anonymously told the
that they believe they heard sexual
assaults and physical violence yeah on
the recording but they could do nothing
about it is that true
that is true and that raises interesting
conflict so maybe Amazon should have
identifiable information in extreme
circumstances if there's a warrant so
you can tie it back but if you do that
then everybody should be much more
weirded about their privacy a very
complicated trade-off there yeah because
you're getting personal information you
can get bank accounts you can get what's
going on in your home whether you're
having marital problems problems at work
with colleagues major Garrett you know
it's not true fully denied absolutely
not true yeah so they're just do you
think that we're getting to the point
Nick where we just shouldn't have these
devices in our homes no I think if you
are having an argument with your spouse
or something you probably shouldn't have
a recording device in that room I mean
we need to be aware those arguments are
not playing absolute Varon fair enough
fair enough
but people need to be much more aware
about these devices if you choose to
have one of these devices in your house
you are putting a recording device in
your house and you should be aware of
the trade-offs it will give you great
benefits timers whether answering
questions but regardless whether a human
is listening to it we all know that
machines are looking at it we all know
that the data is being fed back into the
huge system of Amazon you need to be
aware of what the trade-offs anything
you can do about opt-out or anything
like that you can go into your
preferences now Amazon does not make
this easy but you can go into your Alexa
app on your phone there's a little
hamburger menu on the top you can click
on Alexa privacy and then you have two
choices one you can delete your data and
that will swipe it all away the other
thing you can do is you can click a
little setting that says something like
don't let Amazon use my data to improve
its services it's very it's trying to
push you into not clicking on it but you
can click on it and then your data won't
be fed to the unmarked building in
Romania it occurs to me that if they
wanted to make it easy you could just
say Alexa delete my data they should
actually that's an excellent idea a good
product advice here at the table alright
Nick Thompson always good to have you
here thanks a lot